courneuve le moins qu'on puisse dire de
ces grands ensembles c'est qu'il manque
d'âme on a construit on a paré au plus
pressé et le problème des loisirs de ces
jeunes a été
la dernière roue du carrosse on n'a pas
tellement eu dans jusqu'à présent d'y
penser et tout de même c'est plus clair
c'est les appartements sont beaucoup
plus vastes alors qu'est ce qui manque
bailly manque d'abord d'une part des
maisons des jeunes et de la culture ici
à la courneuve
les deux premiers commerces qui se sont
installés ce sont deux cafés café où on
trouve les fameux flipper de vous
entendez parler souvent cette émission
alors le gros grain la maison de jeunes
le gros oeuvre est terminé mais pour
qu'on puisse aménager l'intérieur on
attend un feu vert préfectoral qui tarde
peut-être un peu à venir depuis députés
comme moi la nouvelle préfecture
d'ailleurs qu'il doit à quoi ces
salaires ça fait jouer hors ligne
parisienne avait envisagé un certain
moment d'y installer ses services
administratifs mais je crois que le
projet a été abandonné
mais en attendant à la courneuve il n'y
a pas de maison des jeunes voyez la voix
si elle n'est pas en service n'ont
absolument pas
alors comme ils n'ont rien à faire
qu'est ce qu'ils font ils s'ennuient et
ils sont livrés les oisifs thaïs promène
le soir dans le centre commercial
ils seront suivis d'ailleurs caméra sur
l'épaule droite ces gars sont allés là
bas
la raison
café sur café banane si ça va bien
moment
non ça ne s'est pas question de sel
n'est pas le diplomate le cargo
jours
une distraction à cet avis
tu écris tu vois là tiens regarde le
moins pour un contat
ça va faire
jouvet
c'est robert downey lui dit comme ça que
tu veux faire un carton
si au milieu il
pendant que son mari au cinéma web